[Music]
what is your reaction to James : well
I'd actually say how is he going to
explain to his grandchildren all of the
lies the deceit all of the problems he's
caused for this country I think a thing
that I've done for the country the
firing of James Comey is going to go
down as a very good thing FBI is great I
know so many people in the FBI the FBI
is a fantastic institution but some of
the people at the top were rotten apples
James Comey was one of them I've done a
great service for this country by
getting rid of them by firing them so
you have no problem explaining this to
your grandchildren that was President
Trump on Fox and Friends talking about
James Comey and joining me now with
reaction is Fox News national security
strategist Sebastian Gorka NRA TV
contributor a former Secret Service
agent Dan bungee no and Fox News
contributor Tammy Bruce all right the
three of you great guests I love having
you all on tonight but I'll start with
I'll start with Uttam because you see
with me thank you women before men you
understand guys right okay so why is it
taking so long to get the information
that we're trying to get and will we
ever get well look they're stonewalling
everyone because there's something to
hide that's normally why you don't hand
over something when you're supposed to
be the morally superior framework you do
that when you want to hide something but
let's remember the president there is
very comfortable it's obvious because at
this point let's remember the context
every single prediction he's made has
come true including one of the earliest
ones where he declared that his campaign
was being spied on he was mocked he was
ridiculed yet clearly note now that has
been confirmed so it people are under
estimating the president when he says
something like that and you should
believe him and he is correct we've seen
the behavior of mr. Comey decline the
nature of his book this spa effectively
the leaking of material that he he wrote
down with meetings with the president
all of these things indicate a man that
has some problems and I will also note
that Jodha jennifer has noted that there
are individuals in the FBI who want to
come and testify talk about what's going
on at the FBI but they need to be
subpoenaed so that they will have
protections against the agency and
Congress will pay their legal bills
whistleblower this is just the beginning
it's so Sebastian Gorka I mean 10 the
President himself declassify some of
this information that we're trying to
get and will that short-circuit the
whole thing absolutely he has
classification Authority uniquely he is
his own adjudicating agency as well so
what he needs to do right now is to
order the declassification of every
document relating to the crossfire
hurricane operation which is political
espionage against another party's
candidate and on top of that the most
important thing that he can do right now
at the stroke of a pen he needs to pull
the clearances of clapper Comey Brennan
and Hillary these what are these people
doing making comments on national
television who's still with clearances
and picking up paychecks from these
people are not in office anymore and
they still have security clearances yes
is that for everybody does George well
he was a president I really care much
about that but what are these people
doing with clearances is there a
requirement of attention to them no is
there any education it's just it's just
tradition that you keep it on to take
their security clearance Bunji no what
do you like to say judge Jim Comey's in
a world of trouble two principal reasons
number one he has yet to explain what
I'm calling paragraph 1 what do I mean
by that when I was a Secret Service
agent you write a case report on a case
paragraph one says how that case started
I received a call about a stolen credit
card wherever it is no one has given us
paragraph 1 on why they started a
counterintelligence investigation
against Trump we've heard three
different stories point number two there
are felony leaks in this case there was
an October 31st leak to the New York
Times about the existence of the case
before they disclose it to Congress and
a leak to the Washington Post about the
investigation into Mike Flynn I believe
by the way that's why they're not
declassifying everything because they
may have a serious felony case against
the leakers I agree look I think the
irony of this is that they thought this
Russia a complaint was going to bring
down Trump and what it's done it's
unlocked the door to show us
level of corruption that none of us
could have imagined and this is where if
and again the mat the right man at the
right time if anyone's got the
discipline to see it through to face
these individuals who've had enormous
worldwide power it's Donald Trump so
this is the man not just of the hour but
a man of fate and this is a time where
we've got to be able to get this done
it's being handed to us and for this is
nonpartisan every individuals got to
care regardless of your party regardless
of what you think of the president
sebastián you only have 15 seconds left
if this is the case and if this thing
was started and they bla they I'm not
gonna say they've lied but they have so
many different starting points it was
July now we know it's a spring I mean
when when is this gonna be over do they
try to just get in in in November and
call it a day and impeach the president
quickly I think Robin mother is going to
try and drop a report that will be used
as a political weapon in the midterms
absolutely but we have to have an
investigation of the political espionage
now judge all right that was good that
was just a few seconds thanks guys